there are advances in the world of ai
image generation and it is 100
nightmare fuel um
got a wave for it
so um this is an example of the
nightmare fuel that uh can be made
with dolly mini there's another thing
called mid journey i've applied to it
it's like a closed beta um but honestly
this one this wasn't this
this one is a certain level of nightmare
fuel that i kind of embrace a little
more there's the mid journey if you look
up
mid-journey journey if you look up what
mid journey can make uh it can actually
make some more um interesting things
that are a little
i hesitate to say better but i think i
actually want to say better because if
you look at that versus looking at this
this is horrifying this is
kind of cool there's a lot of cool stuff
here that um
while not oh
god
oh my god see in unison we did a video
talking about like ai generated art and
it was kind of like the early phases of
all this it wasn't quite where it needed
to be it's all based i think the first
one we looked at was dolly and there
wasn't a lot of options to actually use
it that is
that's really cool we are pretty close
to becoming uh
able to make whatever we want at the
prompt of an ai and have it be really
original interesting stuff so
amy sent me
this thread basically and uh this is a i
generated so this is 1970s cookbook
recipe for raw meat salad this doesn't
exist obviously because raw meat salad
would be terrible and i'm sure that in
some circles this might actually be a
food but to be perfectly honest i
wouldn't want to ever face it because
this is making my skin crawl uh but this
is kind of the idea and then you can do
xenomorphs delight a cookbook about
cooking xenomorphs
which is unpleasant
which is unpleasant but you can see it's
got a lot of detail in it and it's
horrifying
uh
getting attacked by wild dogs at subway
yes it can basically take any prompt and
uh create images out of it and they have
at first glance like if you squint your
eyes and try to defocus it you can see
how
yeah this this could actually work i'm
going to go to the top here and kind of
like go through this so you have
a dog going to the bathroom in the style
of junji ito which if you don't know
junji ito that's the whole this is my
hole who is made for me and then climbs
in the hole and dies osama bin laden
brand cigarettes uh the mcconden burger
[Music]
holy [ __ ] h.r geiger's bag of doritos
a portal to hell opening at a mcdonald's
counter yeah
yeah actually oh god also junji ito's
pizza
[Music]
holy [ __ ] it's just i'm actually kind of
impressed by the symmetry of it but i
don't have access to this right so you
could go through this twitter thread and
maybe when i get access to it i'll try
it but there's something very um
not comforting comforting would be the
wrong word it's actually nowhere near
that whole
uh but you do have dolly mini and i have
this and you can use this for yourself
i'm afraid
i'm afraid that i might give it the hug
of death
eventually it is startling how
recognizable i am in all of these
pictures i don't know if this works with
everybody
i don't know let's see what happens
too much there's a lot of people trying
to use this you just gotta click it a
couple times but i'm again i'm afraid
that we are going to kill it uh please
don't kill it
please don't actually i i just want to
look through more of this it is really
impressive what this is able to make i'm
sure with the right prompts and enough
iterations you can actually get some
pretty cool stuff there's art breeder
art breeder was the
art breeder was the other thing that um
allowed you to make stuff but that was
more mixing pictures that already exist
so it was iterating not that this
doesn't draw inspiration from other
things that actually exist in the art
world it probably does
um
oh
my god but the detail that it's able to
make is is quite fascinating oh god oh
there is wow
it's that weird thing where like out of
the corner of your eye it's like oh that
could be normal but as soon as you look
at it and you really start to take in
the image it gets real bad real quick it
goes from like innocuous and benign to
completely terrifying
and really really truly disturbing this
is
this is all kinds of
awful yeah i'm uncomfortable
who is honest with spaghetti but you can
put in pretty much everything and
anything and it will spit something out
and this kind of gives an insight into
the world of where content creation
based on what a.i can cough up
whereas just a year ago or even like two
years ago it was laughably bad and this
is starting to become laughably not
bad it just becomes something that you
could actually use i know there's a lot
of people that are starting to
generate art like legitimate what they
would call art in
these ai programs and you know to be
perfectly honest this is really
fascinating stuff i don't even know what
kind of prompts they gave to make this
that is i can't look at that that's
tryptophobic but
i mean you know you know what i mean
there's something there there is
something there and it's terrifying of
what that there could be i don't know
where there is i don't know what there
is i don't know why there is but it's
there and you can see how this could
eventually evolve into something where
the art is indistinguishable from
something that someone could make where
the stylistic evocations of your
verbosity in terms of what you can type
into this thing will generate whatever
your mind can desire i could see myself
using this as like a storyboarding tool
where i'm able to make storyboards for
future film projects that i make
based on the stuff that ai generates and
oh my god
oh
wow
oh whoa
oh
okay
that's huh
ah it's weird because like when i when
out of the corner of my eye i think i
see shapes that i don't know if i see
like i kind of see like
a head ahead and this could be ethan and
i
this could be ethan and i
the spirals are very clearly unas honest
um and the spaghetti is clearly
spaghetti most of the time oh my god let
me just go through these for you guys um
yeah but
what happens if i'm using this let's say
for storyboarding purposes and i'm
making these things with the idea that
i'm just going to eventually make
something else off of it
but what happens when ai becomes good
enough to make videos based on prompts
completely generated it would start off
really terrible almost nauseating to
watch i bet because of the way that it
generates it however what happens later
on when that starts leveraging tools
that are already accessible it's not
just making images based on interpreted
colors and positions of pixels where
it's like leveraging let's say unreal
engine 5 and you give it a prompt and
the the ai is like i have this tool to
make things and it just makes it what
happens then when it can make something
from a prompt that is not as good as
something i could hand craft just like
many of these images aren't as good as
something that somebody could handcraft
um because even these you can see that
it has like flaws and stuff but you know
the flaws are kind of endearing for it
or
whatever you would want endearing and
endearing well what happens when it
could start to make videos that are just
as good as anything anyone else could
make what if you could put in a prompt
and you get a whole movie out of it
that's kind of the future scary possible
who knows but that's the future
so in the meantime i'm not trying to
meme on it
i feel like i shouldn't use this for my
own vanity markiplier with massive
gumbos while that's cranking on that i'm
going to go through some more of these
austin powers eating a sandwich at
subway it's kind of funny because i put
in subway and the other thing
maybe because it said eating a sandwich
in some way it kind of had contextual
information to be like oh man subway the
restaurant i also put out a tweet
uh and other people understandably i did
markiplier with a knife and other people
understandably also tried this i kind of
want to see what they make
except a guy with a gun
markiplier with kung fu
all right
that one
the bottom one here
i love that markiplier with a gun yep
look at the [ __ ] beef arm on this
girl
i'm ripping through my shirt my i'm
sucking my own face into myself but that
you know he i'm doing what happened with
a gun and a knife the knife went through
my face oh no
oh
god
that's scary
oh
okay
markiplier's saving private ryan that is
weirdly good
that is shockingly good
that is shockingly good
oh
no
no
no no
no no
no
no don't grab the camera okay all right
let's do
i believe naked on a roof i'll let you
think about that one dolly mini and
dolly too did come out
i want to just detour quickly to
something else that dolly can do uh
that's really interesting dolly mini is
based on dolly one this is dolly e2
so you've got and i i wonder if mid
journey is kind of based on it too but
honestly i have no idea so you got an
astronaut riding a horse in
photorealistic style he's also got in
the style of andy warhol
as a pencil drawing you've got
teddy bears in realistics are mixed
sparkling chemicals as mad scientists as
a 1990s saturday morning cartoon digital
art steampunk style
bowl of soup portal to another dimension
as digital art basket drawn
that looks like a monster as a planet in
the universe mixed media digital art
you've got so many different things
that you can have
spray painted on a wall that
legitimately looks like a spray painting
on a wall made out of plastine scene i
don't even know what that is
astronaut lounging this is all ai
generated and there's many different
varieties of it for each of these
all spontaneously made by a program kind
of terrifying when you really think
about it when you really start to think
about it it's kind of scary
kids crayon art it's weird it's weird
because it can do photo looking things
as if it looked like a photograph and it
has that quality where it really truly
does look like a photo taken especially
that one my god that one legitimately
looks just like someone took a photo of
this that's terrifying
and cool and terrifying
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no
no
oh my god
who are you who are you
no
oh god no
oh my god
oh my god
i want to see what it does for me doing
a backflip let me see what other people
have
come up
[Laughter]
all right with
that's that's unrelated
um
i love the space memes i love the space
memes
food for the first time
oh god i love it in the nba ah that
looks pretty good
good god markiplier in space look at
don't look at that look at these look at
these look at these oh look at my oven
mitts look at these
cat with a knife us you know cat's not
bad
okay cat's pretty bad the more i look at
it but it's not bad but also it's bad
markiplier french toast
ooh
markiplier is a muppet oh
[Laughter]
just all the pictures of me running for
me
i love the the uh freaking bigfoot me
god oh i hate it i love it i hate it
with a bazooka ver
that's very good that's very good that's
very good whoa
look
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
god that is
oh my god that's very funny
the only one that
that kinda could be me is this one down
here but man that's that's really i like
how it just got a streak of red here
because like oh your marble has red hair
i got it that's very funny okay
i love the bazooka that's quite good
markiplier for playstation 2.
wow
that fits
that's so weird
mark flyer at fnaf darkiplier i can't
believe it got that that's shocking that
one's really good that was not bad that
one's creepy and good in a way the weird
fleshy tie oh these are quite good
oon is honest again with the spirals
it's actually getting and you can see
the silhouettes it almost looks like fan
art eating a sandwich
the this bottom that's not a sandwich
since that ain't a sandwich
where is mothman
[Music]
that's good stuff markiplier with a pony
[Laughter]
oh it's a good video i remember that
[Laughter]
very good video
uh who's cutting onions
wow
oh my god oh man lichtstein should you
lexi and you should use these for uh
three scary games video uh pictures the
jump scares at the beginning you don't
need to make any more ever i love this
picture
i hate this picture pokemon with the
knife
[Music]
oh why the lip why are the lips like
that why
oh
god the more i look at it
it's because your brain just tries to
make sense of it and the longer you look
at the more your brain just like throws
errors
without holding a can of del monte corn
and milk do you have milk and a can of
corn
i think that might be okay with a spear
[Music]
why does it look like chica
horrifying chica but it does kinda you
know for some reason
lady domitre looks a bit like
chica sometimes markiplier meets matpat
oh god this is how you know you're gonna
die in seven days what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
what
see that's pretty good i don't know why
these are good why is darkiplier turning
out well why is it turning out well why
do those actually look good whereas
everything else looks terrible oh my god
okay let's see what we got here regular
naked
oh my god no
oh god it's awful it's i have to click
through them okay
holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh
no
god
it is
horrible
no
okay all right
okay uh actually no i want to try
what does it do for like other
dark characters markiplier eating
markiplier oh no
oh no the markiplier is screaming
oh what is
wow oh man that's
[ __ ] hilarious
holy [ __ ]
oh my god
[Music]
whoa
under wat wow how is it able to do
underwater so good
clearly it's like my face slapped onto
some underwater stuff why is that a
picture in a picture
why why is that like that that is very
strange
horrible oh that's actually quite good
oh that's not bad
that's pretty good
oh that's
from the meat canyon video
good great okay we tapped out on that
one what do we have here
see why does this turn out it's not good
but it's definitely better than the
other ones why there's something more
it's like crisper it's more clear the
clarity is up why would the clarity be
up just from doing those types of
characters that doesn't make a lot of
sense let me do
i'll do this
hiya
lexian don't put any of this in i'm just
waiting i don't have any others to look
at you better not be putting this in
wham
you better not boom
don't put this in bam
don't try it
boom
don't put it in whoa
whoa
that's crazy
again they're not like
extremely high quality things clearly
like low res but for some reason like
the edges of this suit it's so clearly a
suit the face is all kinds of whatever
but it's so clearly a suit and so
clearly in space
it's weird it's weird it's weirdly good
somehow it knows that darker blur
typically is in a suit so it's pulling
from suit-based things
but also just like
like that's really cool
oh that's horrifying but it kind of fits
you know
that one's just messed up there
it's just it's weird
anyway i'm gonna leave this up there
this is kind of a view into what the
world of ai generated art is starting to
get into which it is starting to get a
little deeper into this world of content
creation and there is a place for it i
think anyway especially with dolly too
like if i wanted to film something in
this scene with the in this way it gives
options to do stuff like that and
quickly made this in like a minute and a
half
made all of these in like a minute and a
half it's scary but cool it's exciting
you know change can be scary but change
can also be good i think there is
potential for this to be used in a way
that only fuels further creativity and
also at the same time it may run us all
into relevancy why would we even do
anything in the first place if an ai
could do it better than we ever could
that's a future problem for future us
not me right now so thank you everybody
so much for watching i'm not going to
link this in the description because i'm
afraid you're going to kill the website
if you want to find it you can find it
yourself by searching for it thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to check out other stuff that i
made to like in space with markiplier
where a lot of those memes came from
it's available in the link description
or the end card when this video comes to
its inevitable doom thank you again
everybody for watching let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and if you've got any more ai based
stuff uh let me know what you think of
that i am uh currently interning with
corridor crew uh where i'm learning a
lot of stuff they are very into this
stuff and a lot of this kind of like was
uh shown to me they have access to a lot
of these tools too because they are
super interested in this kind of stuff
and it's always exciting to learn what's
on the cutting edge of things and see
how things progress from what was to
what will be and even this what i'm
showing you right here is not even close
to the cutting edge of what could be
done thank you and as always i will see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you